[Music]
let's get straight to the point how many
Godzillas are there in the monsterverse
you might think this is a crazy question
of course it's just one the one and only
Gman but you would be wrong as there
have been quite a few others although
dead as of the present times remember
Godzilla is just a member of a Titan
super species the last living specimen
so who are all the members of the
Godzilla species that we know of firstly
yeah of course we have Godzilla the
current king of the monsters he was the
one that first appeared in Awakening
well chronologically and then
disappeared and came up back in 2014
defeated the mutos defeated Muto Prime
evolved into the 2019 version during the
timeline of the legacy of monsters and
continued to be in that current form
till the present times he fought with
Kong and Mecha Godzilla in GVK and will
be fighting shimu and scaring in gxk
interestingly Greg key turned Godzilla
as still being an adolescent before the
Titan War defeated by the Rival Kong in
the hollow Earth which means the 2019
form could be his adult stage a young
adult so the second Godzilla scene in
the monsterverse appeared in the comics
Godzilla Aftershock and he is Deon Deon
has the 2014 virgin body and was
defeated by the mutual Prime in battle
in 1100 BC in Japan he did not die in
the fight though he was killed later by
the growing mut sport deep inside his
body he later succumbed to the parasitic
infestation in the Philippines years
later he was the same dead Godzilla that
was seen in Godzilla 2014 where the male
mut Spore emerged from and headed to
Japan Deon was worshiped in the ancient
times by the Phoenicians and when he was
discovered by Monarch they gave him the
title species 541 6
Adam the third Godzilla that we know of
was also seen as a dead body in Godzilla
Aftershock that was discovered by Emma
Russell and the Monarch team deep in the
Frozen Russian Heartland he is the
Siberian specimen this Godzilla like
deeon was also defeated and impregnated
with spores by the mut Prime and in the
same way as deeon it died due to the
spores inside its body feeding off of
his radiation rich blood and draining
his life force in a gradual and painful
manner not much is known about the time
period of its death but it was stated to
be from a different Epoch which would
mean in geological times hundreds of
thousands of years prior to Deon
therefore an older
specimen then next we have the mega
goira this is the one that was seen in
GVK as a dead specimen in the throne
room of the Kongs as a skull in terms of
General appearance the only notable
remains of it is a skull which is
significantly larger than Godzilla's
head it has sharp teeth with two large
prominent upper canine teeth resembling
those of saber-tooth cats and relatively
large front-facing Optical cavities
which means he might have been an
evolved version in the film novelization
the creature is implied to be the
remains of titanis goera based on its
physical resemblance this is
contradicted by the movie however as the
creature's skull is noticeably more
Maman than reptilian possessing
elongated canines but as far as the
novelization is concerned it is a guira
speci an
individual next we have the peran
Godzilla yeah yeah some of you might
think no that's Godzilla the current one
but let's take a step back and think
critically shall we Greg Keys stated
that Godzilla was an adolesent in the
times of the Titan War which means that
he couldn't have been the same large
specimen an adult 250 million years back
I for one think that the enemity between
Godzilla and the shinamura species was
Instinct based and not a personal
rivalry but one thing is for sure though
if the peran Godzilla the ancient one
was a different individual then it shows
that their Titan species had little to
no evolutionary jumps they were perfect
being the same size and shape as
always then yes lastly we have the Zilla
halawa wait a minute isn't this Godzilla
for sure well yes and no zoah halawa
doesn't mean the specific Godzilla it
translates from E to English as the
great enemy which could have been either
Godzilla or his entire species during
the hollow Earth Titan War this is
evident by the cave painting scene in
GVK art book showcasing two Godzilla
specimens and in other sources they are
called his ancestors that means that
these two titanis Gojira specimens were
both Z laah halawa yeah they could also
be just Deon and Godzilla or either one
of them with another older specimen so
this brings us to the conclusion I usion
in the monster verse we have one living
Godzilla the current king of the
monsters and four dead ones and probably
two more that were active in the Titan
War which means that this is the first
time ever in Earth's history that
Godzilla is completely
alone so if you like this video then
watch this one as well and if you're
more interested in other movie monsters
and content then check out our Channel
as well we might just have things that
you haven't seen or heard before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
one take care fam